welcome to the stream I'm currently in
the Paramount Theater in Denver Colorado
and we are about to get underway with
the warm-ups before we do the show
tonight I still have to practice my
guitar but there's something that I
wanted to show you before we get started
I just climbed a bunch of stairs and I'm
incredibly out of shape so bear with me
for a moment so this is the Paramount
Theater and there's a deep dark secret
lurking within the halls of the
Paramount Theater that you guys don't
fully understand everybody's who's
coming to the show tonight has no idea
what's in store for them so I just
wanted to gird your loins before you
actually get to the theater and know the
disaster that strikes you see that
doorway over there behind that doorway
is something that I've never seen before
never in all my life have I seen
something so terrifying is what exists
behind that doorway and so just so I
wanted to warn you guys before you ever
got close to this theater is like you
need to avoid that because whoever is
standing by these seats
whoever seated here I don't think
they're gonna make it out if you know
what I mean so anyway let me just they
get a look I mean you can get a look at
the stage at 100 but that's not the
point here
the point here is that there's a whole
lot of death lurking in here because
we've been to numerous theaters already
and they have been every sort of haunted
that you could imagine but this one in
particular it's even more haunted than
you could ever hope
to imagine so everybody stay low get
ready okay all right it doesn't look so
bad there it's gonna kind of Stairway
not sure what there's another door in
the beyond I'm not sure where that leads
but I can smell the Sun of death if you
guys can't understand what's going on
you just got here we are in the middle
of a very dangerous place and I'm gonna
brave it because you guys who are coming
to the theater you don't know what
you're in for
you don't know what lies in the darkness
of these halls you don't know what is
here and I'm gonna try to protect you so
that you can make it out because if I
don't then you can so come with me and
stay as low as you can okay
now I can only hope that whatever dark
entity lies within these halls he's
forgiving enough to know that I'm
curious more than I haven't Antigonish
dick okay
I'm gonna peek you guys out there trust
me you guys are wanna go God want gonna
want to go first
what do you see did you see something
did you hear that I think you guys want
to disturb something okay I'm gonna go
alone we're gonna do this together okay
all right everybody just stay as quiet
as you can at this point I'm not ready
to say that you guys shouldn't come to
this theater but wait there's something
under there do you guys see I don't know
what that was
did it look at you did you see did you
see
look I don't know what that was maybe it
was nothing maybe it was same tricks on
myself
I ran someone and I don't know where I
thought I was going back the way I came
but I wasn't I went down another
corridor and I don't know what I saw
before me there's some kind of landmark
maybe we'll be able to get out of here
alive some kind of darkroom I can tell I
see lights in the darkness and I don't
like it okay we're gonna keep going
forward as best we can we've got some
kind of machinery in this room I can
only imagine that it's torture I don't
want to know what's up that letter
I can smell blood here some kind of sick
sweep decay in the air you know I don't
know what these are they're huge I don't
know where I am anymore I kind of lost
my bearing this is giant machines dirty
windows old broken tools I got no sense
of where I am no landmark no nothing
okay everybody just stay as low as you
can and stay as quiet as you can
I'm showing you the dark dirty recesses
of this theater okay now if if in all my
years I know a trap when I see one and
this yeah that's a goddamn trap you
ain't gonna fool me in thinking that
there's an exit over there but the
curious thing is why is there a lock as
a lock on this door
hello
Oh run run